the shifting sand info cap in the
southern tip of madagascar blankets
everything
it's threatening livelihoods and burying
homes and buildings this was the police
station
and this the local government office now
so covered were able to stand on its
roof
the phenomenon known here as teomina or
red storm has been dramatically changing
this indian ocean coastline ravaging
crops and stifling development
the people here have been hit by a long
drought but also fierce winds which
often halt the fishing which is one of
the main sources of income
henry claude the head of the village
hasn't been out on the water for more
than a week now
some of the brave or the desperate opt
for other methods but it can be
dangerous and often fruitless
henry claude shows us the rows of sizal
trees the village has planted to try to
restore this degraded land and rescue
the ecosystem
it's a long-term strategy with the
greenest of weapons
how worried are you
that even more of the village is going
to be buried in sand many of them are
just plain scared not just of the future
but they're here and now
we're afraid of living here he says and
many people are leaving
they're afraid of the invasion by the
dunes and we just can't get investment
here
the violent winds blow off roofs and
make a living that's already hard even
harder
and there are signs many of the
villagers have already abandoned their
homes and been forced to move on
so they're turning to other ways to
survive
and by the look of this market
madagascar's forests are being plundered
and sold at an alarming rate
the main thing that's being sold at this
market is wood with only 15
of the population with access to
electricity they've had to turn to
chopping down trees
just to generate their own fuel they
also
make charcoal which they then go on to
sell just to try to eke out a living
every day
but all this has added to large-scale
deforestation with madagascar losing 40
percent of its forest since the 1950s
we don't have anything to eat we don't
have anything to drink we cut the wood
because of the kerei he says
kerei is what the malagasy called the
drought that brings hunger
cassie will be lucky if she sells any of
her sweet potatoes she'll maybe make 2
000 ariari about half a dollar but she
has seven other children as well as her
baby
it's hard she says i'll spend half on
water and half on rice for the baby
[Music]
and right now madagascar is burning away
its future to get through the present
racking up one of the highest rates of
deforestation in any tropical country
that's put its ecosystem at risk
destroying its habitat and putting the
vast range of unique wildlife it's home
to in great danger
we spotted an extremely rare radiated
tortoise out in the open and lifted it
away from the road it's critically
endangered and only found here in the
south of madagascar but it's being
killed for its meat or captured by
poachers at such a rate that
conservationists warn it could disappear
from the wild forever within 20 years
creatures are now very much at risk
because the situation is so critical in
madagascar that they fetch a huge price
on the black market and if any of these
are smuggled to order usually out to the
far eastern markets they can raise
thousands and thousands
of dollars
but if caught
you face a very stiff prison sentence
the people of this island are among the
poorest in the world yet the country has
an abundance of natural riches with more
than 100 different species of lima
living in the wild for instance and the
island so large it's more than double
the size of britain
that there are different but equally
serious problems across the nation as we
found when we traveled here into the
forest on the eastern coast
this is a protected forest
but there are so many more areas of
madagascar which are being destroyed
it's incredible to think that there are
hundreds and hundreds of species here in
madagascar that you will not find
anywhere else
in the world
and many conservationists believe that
they are now
in danger
sinji has been traveling through this
forest for two decades he's never seen
it so bad
it's not good to change the trend coming
hot
high hot
and dry
right
and
the rain coming
if they come
rain too much no stop
and flood everywhere
the malagasy government has so many
tough challenges and weaning its
population off its dependence on coal
and wood is just one of them and right
now for so many here raiding the
nation's natural resources is seen as
the only way to survive
alex crawford sky news in the grand sue
region of madagascar